[Applauso]
quando parlo di medicina rigenerativa
quando dico che mi occupo di medicina
rigenerativa
la prima reazione delle persone cioè
esattamente cos'è che fai e per arrivare
a spiegarlo partiamo proprio dal
concetto di quando la passione incontra
la ragione una delle grandi passioni
dell'uomo che sono spesso associate alla
ragione è l'amore per la conoscenza la
voglia di studiare di capire di
conoscere di rendersi conto di come
funzionano le cose perché questo ci dà
la sensazione di poter controllare gli
eventi dominare il nostro futuro
prevedere ed essere artefici della
nostra fortuna della nostra
sopravvivenza ed è qualche cosa che
permea permea la nostra esistenza sempre
fin da piccoli spesso nei giochi ma
questo tipo di passione è qualche cosa
che appartiene veramente all'uomo sin
dai tempi più antichi e ha portato al
tentativo di cercare di raggiungere
queste su questa mitica sostanza la
pietra filosofale in grado di bloccare
di eliminare la corruzione della materia
quindi di trasformare in italy in oro e
donare all uomo la sopravvivenza origina
diciamo nelle prime nei primi report su
questo tipo di cose dai tempi degli
antichi greci da un mito greco ma è
estremamente diffuso è stato
estremamente diffuso anche tra gli arabi
nel medioevo e si è diffuso in tutta
europa
quindi è qualche cosa che descrive la
voglia di conoscenza e la voglia di
mutare gli eventi e di poterli
controllare da parte dell'uomo tanto che
ai primi dell'ottocento mary shelley
scrisse nel
il suo romanzo su frankenstein dove
l'uomo addirittura ricostruiva se stesso
prendendo delle parti corrotte della
materia riusciva a combinarle insieme
per poter creare un uomo nuovo frutto
della sua manipolazione e non di eventi
incontrollati questa voglia di conoscere
la materia ha portato a spaziare nei
settori più svariati e tra le sostanze
più svariate e fra le cose positive le
cose negative una delle cose che abbiamo
scoperto è stata l'energia nucleare
l'energia nucleare che purtroppo in
tempi più recenti ha portato a dei
disastri importanti ha portato a morti
sofferenze cose molto brutte
tuttavia nulla riesce a essere
completamente negativo evidentemente c'è
sempre qualche cosa qualche risvolto
positivo in tutte le cose
e da questa terribile esperienza è nata
la scoperta delle cellule staminali gli
individui che avevano avuto dei danni a
seguito dell'insediamento avevano avuto
un comportamento particolare strano
spesso non morivano subito ma avevano in
una fase successiva anemie infezioni
come se il loro sangue fosse deserto
questo ha portato gli scienziati a
cominciare a capire determinati
meccanismi e quindi a far riprodurre
l'esperimento su animali di laboratorio
ea scoprire che il tocco irradiato aveva
effettivamente la formazione di questo
sangue deserto in grado non più in grado
di produrre un sistema immunitario che
potesse difenderlo dai batteri che ci
circondano nella realtà e nella vita di
tutti i giorni nell'ambiente
tuttavia si scoperse anche che se in
questo topino danneggiato noi infondeva
mo delle cellule staminali del midollo
osseo
il topino sopravviveva perché si riforma
va da queste cellule l'intero tessuto
nato poetico cioè il sangue con tutti i
suoi componenti e lui diventava di nuovo
immunocompetente capace di difendersi
dai microbi quando il topino veniva
infuso invece con cellule del midollo
osseo ma non staminali dopo meno di sei
mesi
moriva di nuovo per anemie infezioni
quindi questo ha portato una sorta di
entusiasmo
sensazione di poter controllare questo
strumento perché era in grado di
ridonare la vita anche in condizioni
estreme a degli esseri viventi e la fase
successiva che ha portato al grande
entusiasmo è stato rendersi conto che
potevamo addirittura estrarre le cellule
completamente dall'organismo coltivarle
e se quello che avevamo fatto era fatto
bene in maniera scientificamente
rilevante queste cellule mantenevano le
loro capacità vedete nella foto delle
cellule embrionali di topo verdi sono
state rimesse dopo le manipolazioni in
laboratorio nella mamma topo e hanno
dato origine un topo verde che significa
che queste cellule non mantenuto la loro
capacità di fare peli pelle ossa occhi
intestino cuore fegato tutto
completamente nonostante le
manipolazioni al di fuori dell'essere
vivente e questo è un passo epocale che
ha portato un grande entusiasmo la
sensazione di poter fare qualsiasi cosa
grazie a questo strumento quindi
studiare le patologie studiare i farmaci
i difetti genetici e ricostruire dei
pezzi di ricambio
questo ha stuzzicato ovviamente
grandemente la fantasia dei media degli
artisti e ha cominciato a creare l'idea
vedete le immagini su focus su wired gli
organi ricostruiti in provetta in
piastre di coltura in national
geographic immaginava delle teche piene
dei vari organi la fabbrica degli organi
descritta dal sole 24 ore e il famoso
film il replicante blade runner
proprio sulla scia di questa delirio
quasi di onnipotenza dell'uomo con
questo strumento nelle mani ma quando
parliamo di staminali di che cosa si
parla perché è un discorso che viene
spesso nei giornali descritto in maniera
un pochino confusa quando noi parliamo
di qualche cosa di questi strumenti che
ci possono servire per ricostruire delle
parti di noi per ripristinare delle
funzioni normalmente ci riferiamo a tre
tipi di
cellule staminali embrionali quelle
cosiddette ips che sono delle adulte
fate diventare embrionali e le cellule
staminali adulte
vediamo velocemente le embrionali sono
ovviamente prese dall'embrione in
particolar modo da quel mucchietto di
cellule in una certa fase dello sviluppo
e sono in teoria capaci di fare
qualsiasi cosa qualsiasi tessuto però
sono sempre allogeniche cioè di un altro
individuo per che l'embrione ovviamente
non sarà il nostro ma sarà quello di
qualcun altro e ed è sono un tipo di
cellule che in molti individui crea dei
problemi etici perché e disturba molte
categorie di persone l'idea di
dissociare un potenziale essere vivente
per utilizzarlo per scopi anche
terapeutici le ips sono una scoperta per
il quale il premio nobel yamaha nata
appunto vinse nobel nel 2012 e sono
sostanzialmente delle cellule adulte
quindi queste possono essere le nostre
le stesse del nostro organismo
nelle quali vengono infilati tramite
delle tecniche di biologia molecolare
quattro geni poi si è scoperto che
potevano essere anche tre questi geni ma
è lo stesso il meccanismo che sono delle
molecole spesse nell'embrione quando
vengono inserite nelle cellule staminali
adulte queste tornano a essere
embrionali qui si bypassa il problema
etico ci sono cellule nostre quindi il
nostro sistema immunitario le riconosce
tuttavia il problema che diventano
capaci di fare qualsiasi cosa e noi gli
dobbiamo saper dire dare istruzioni
precise perché facciano quello che
vogliamo noi e non qualsiasi cosa
altrimenti l'individuo morirebbe di un
tumore embrionale che si chiama teratoma
e questo non è sempre facile
infine abbiamo le cellule staminali
adulte che sono sempre state un pochino
più facili da manipolare perché loro
sapevano già fare il loro lavoro
andavano tranquille verso il loro
obiettivo e quindi bastava non
interferire con la loro azione era
difficile riconoscerle bisognava
trovarle nei diversi distretti non è
stato sempre facile individuarle in
alcuni casi non sono ancora state
individuate
quindi sulla base di tutto questo
abbiamo tutti questo pannello di
strumenti abbiamo imparato tante belle
cose siamo riusciti a costruire pezzi di
ricambio perché questo è quello che ci
chiede la società questo è quello che ci
chiedono i pazienti ci siete riusciti a
che cosa è servito tutto questo studio
la buona notizia è che sì ci siamo
riusciti ci siamo riusciti certo non
tutte le volte che avremmo voluto però
ci siamo riusciti nel 1984 l'uomo è
stato capace l'uomo in questione era un
professore di harvard di ricostruire una
parte di se stesso cioè di isolare le
cellule staminali dal corpo e
ricostruire l'intero tessuto
dell'epidermide umana in laboratorio e
trapiantarlo su un paziente ustionato
salvandogli la vita è stato un passo
epocale infatti lo associato
all'immagine di un del della scoperta
della luna perché la prima volta in cui
l'uomo si costruiva il pezzo di ricambio
che era andato perduto con delle
tecniche di laboratorio
subito dopo nel 1986 il team di lavoro
di cui ho fatto parte io e ha fatto
parte il professor de luca è stato in
grado di riprodurre la tecnologia in
europa e trattare franco che aveva 18
anni 86 per cento di ustioni di terzo
grado sulla superficie corporea e
salvargli la vita
questo e lui nel 2014 è ancora vivo ma
la foto del 2014 che è sopravvissuto e
con qualche cicatrice ma felice di
essere vivo e tornato tante volte a
trovarci e non basta perché quando si
vede un successo quando si vede che ci
si può riuscire
viene la voglia di andare avanti di
provare a raggiungere altri obiettivi di
fare di raggiungere altri traguardi e
quindi il mio team di lavoro questa
volta nel 1997 approvato la ri
costruzione in laboratorio della
superficie dell'occhio umano quella
lentina trasparente che abbiamo davanti
che noi vediamo colorata perché vediamo
l'iride sotto che ci consente il
passaggio della luce il passaggio della
e quindi la visione per pazienti che
avevano perduto la funzione visiva
questa è la
superficie corneale ricostruite in
laboratorio così come la vediamo ancora
adesso ancora oggi che viene fatta con
le cellule dello stesso paziente
prendendo un prelievo piccolo di un
millimetro riusciamo a ricostruire
entrambi gli occhi
e questi sono gli occhi e curati che
recuperano completamente la loro
superficie della loro funzione visiva e
la loro stabilità vedete quanti anni
hanno indicati
dopo il trapianto e ancora i loro occhi
funzionano perfettamente
veramente un ripristino di quello che
era prima come se non fosse successo
niente
è una cosa straordinaria e poi la
ricostruttivo recente che ha fatto un
pochino il giro del mondo in alla fine
dell'anno scorso la ricostruzione
dell'epidermide con un genoma modificato
vedete quel bambino era in germania di
origini siriane aveva perduto
completamente tutta l'epidermide la sua
superficie corporea e stava morendo era
in coma farmacologico per tollerare
indolore e si stava aspettando che
morisse
abbiamo provato a prendere le sue
staminali della pelle modificare il
genoma per inserire il gene che gli
mancava e ricostruire tutta la sua
superficie corporea e trapiantargli la
sua pelle geneticamente modificata siamo
riusciti e dopo quasi due anni dal
trapianto abbiamo comunicato
ufficialmente al mondo scientifico la
notizia e alla fine dell'anno scorso
questa notizia ha fatto il giro del
mondo perché la pelle è l'organo più
grande che noi abbiamo molto importante
questo e lui si chiama slam quando essa
è uscito dall'ospedale oggi va a scuola
e gioca a calcio e ancora altri team di
ricerca hanno potuto ricostruire il
sistema immunitario funzionante per
curare i bambini in bolla quelli che
sono privi di difese verso i microbi e
l'ambiente esterno salvandogli la vita
questa volta il team del san raffaele di
milano ci siamo fatti l'idea che con le
staminali e la medicina rigenerativa si
poteva fare qualsiasi cosa a diventare
come brad pitt nel mio caso magari
angelina jolie che è meglio però almeno
per me è questo questo tipo di
convinzione e questa sensazione di poter
fare qualsiasi cosa un po alimentato
anche dai media purtroppo che hanno un
po esagerato ha portato qualcuno come
spesso accade ad approfittarne per cui
persone come vannoni che era laureato in
lettere non in medicina ha proposto il
metodo stamina dichiarando un sacco di
falsità biologiche scientifiche e anche
proprio nel riportare i fatti realmente
accaduti o excel in germania perché non
siamo solo gli italiani essere
imbroglioni e per carità siamo belli
distribuiti in tutto il mondo che hanno
proposto dei trattamenti a base di
cellule che invece
producevano dei gravi eventi avversi e
questo va beh quella di the stata chiusa
e staminali e volendo anche è però
purtroppo ce ne sono altre e alimentando
il turismo sanitario ci possiamo
difendere da queste cose da quelli che
strumentalizzano qualcosa che invece
sarebbe una cosa bella una cosa creata
per il rispetto della salute della vita
dei pazienti si ci possiamo difendere lo
possiamo fare perché il nostro corpo ha
delle caratteristiche straordinarie
noi siamo in grado di produrre 300
miliardi di nuove cellule ogni giorno
200 milioni al minuto
noi siamo voi siete dei supereroi avete
un cuore che batte un milione di volte
al giorno
e mentre batte un milione di volte al
giorno meglio del percussioni di da matt
immaginatevi qualcosa del genere dentro
di voi continuamente spompa 6 litri di
sangue attraverso 120 mila chilometri di
vasi sanguigni nel vostro organismo
produce un milione virgola 2 di
eritrociti globuli rossi
ogni giorno per rimpiazzarne altrettanti
che muoiono ea un sistema di difesa che
è più potente del più potente dei
presidenti della più potente delle
nazioni quindi siamo veramente dei
supereroi siamo veramente qualcosa che
deve essere rispettato che va trattato
con cura perché è veramente splendido ma
soprattutto il nostro cervello
abbiamo un cervello che in questo
momento mentre voi siete qui che se
credete di svolgere come unica
operazione l'ascolto di quello che io ti
sto dicendo in realtà il vostro cervello
sta facendo miliardi di attività
perfettamente armoniosamente coordinate
perché sta regolando il funzionamento
del cuore dell'inter stino del fegato
del cervello della sudorazione della
crescita del pelo del rinnovo
dell'epidermide de il milione 2d ritro
ci sta facendo una quantita di cose
incredibili
quindi c'è un genio dentro di noi
usiamolo non buttiamolo nelle mani di un
apprendista stregone quando ci vengono
proposte delle terapie noi che facciamo
ci delle domande tante come facciamo a
sapere se possiamo essere sicuri se si
possa
e dal di chi c'è davanti prima che una
terapia di queste arrivi a un paziente
quindi che divenga proposte devono
essere state prodotte tante
pubblicazioni scientifiche su riviste
specializzate
chiedete i riferimenti informatevi fate
tante domande cercate se questi lavori
scientifici esistono altrimenti non è
vero niente
altrimenti è una truffa non solo ma
avere quanti più elementi possibili di
servirà per chiedere tante altre
opinioni confrontate l'opinione con
tanta gente con tanti specialisti non il
vicino di casa magari a meno che non sia
uno specialista per carità e poi il
consenso informato chi vi propone una
terapia seriamente vi proporrà un costi
deve proporre un consenso informato che
vi spieghi tutto quello che vi fanno
quali sono le basi scientifiche del
trattamento qual è il meccanismo
d'azione e che cosa potreste fare in
alternativa a quello molto in dettaglio
dovete sapere tutto per evitare di
cascare nelle mani di una persona
sbagliata io concludo dicendo vi che
quando seppi della prima ricostruzione
di un tessuto umano in laboratorio fuori
dal corpo umano per la ricostruzione di
un pezzo di persona cui veramente
folgorata fulminata dal dall'emozione e
pensai quella è la via quella è la nuova
via della medicina quello dobbiamo fare
perché precisa perché è potente perché
in grado di riprodurre tutte le funzioni
del nostro organismo e sa è una cosa
adatta a noi non altera i nostri
equilibri e rifatta con i nostri pezzi
quindi è una cosa straordinaria
insieme tutti insieme soprattutto anche
gli stessi pazienti
dobbiamo cooperare per evitare che
questo gioiello questa possibilità di
ricostruire dei pezzi di essere umano
vengano male utilizzati per scopi
personali
[Applauso]
[Musica]